let me ask you a question have you ever
felt powerful and if so when was the
last time you felt truly powerful like
your steps have extra weight to them you
have a steely-eyed focus the decisions
that you make have Clarity obviously
it's impossible to feel like this all
the time life will throw a plethora of
things that will sort of knock you off
the straight and narrow path it will
make you feel powerless or humiliated or
anxious embarrassed nervous but
hopefully we're able to come back to
that feeling of empowerment that feeling
of strength if it's been a while since
you felt this feeling of internal calm
and power and presence then in this
video I want to talk about a strategy
that I have for converting the
situations of life as various as they
may be into internal power and I know
that sounds very woo-woo but hopefully
by the end of this video you understand
where I'm coming from So You you can use
it to your advantage so that you can
feel more powerful more often you can
truly be gigachad I'm sure gigachad
feels like this 24 7. he is the spirit
of this internal benevolent power and in
order to feel this way we need to be
aware of Snakes and Ladders
[Music]
now
[Music]
now in life it's no surprise that there
are lots of places to go things to see
things to do but if we are not aware of
what's a snake and what's a ladder we'll
do certain things and go certain places
and partake in particular activities
that will either increase our power or
decrease it the things that increase our
power are ladders and the things that
decrease our power are snakes so how do
you identify a snake and a ladder in
order to properly identify what's a
snake and what's a ladder we need to
figure out a little bit more about our
psychology now our brain has many
chemicals chemicals that make us feel
very different ways the present-oriented
chemicals include oxytocin endorphins
serotonin and endocannabinoids these
brain chemicals allow us to experience
and Savor the present moment what we
have right here and right now dopamine
is concerned with what we don't yet have
it makes us desire things we can attain
in the immediate or distant future it
says you should do this thing because
you will get a reward and it's important
to realize that these two types of brain
chemicals work in tandem usually things
are some degree of satisfying and some
degree of tempting but the weird thing
is some things are extremely tempting
and we feel a huge urge to do these
things but they're not that satisfying
this is a snake we live in a culture
that creates activities that are
lopsided in construction front loaded
with so much dopamine so much Intrigue
and temptation to do them but the
satisfaction is usually all right and it
expires quickly snakes make you lose
power they waste your time energy and
attention on things that give you a net
loss return on investment Desire with
without satisfaction Intrigue without
resolution the goal is to find
activities that have the right balance
dopaminergic enough that there's
incentive to do them but satisfying and
enjoyable enough that they give you a
feeling of empowerment and fulfillment
in return you have a deep sense of
feeling like it was worth it it gave you
something that you can take forward into
life thing things that make you feel
better about yourself and your life
after having done them these are the
ladders so before you dive into any
activity that you usually do ask
yourself is this a snake or is this a
ladder how can I tell well how do I feel
before I do it am I very tempted to do
it is there this like magnetic draw to
do it how do I feel while I do it and
how will I feel directly after I do it
and later in the day after having done
it and maybe even a day after I do it
and a week after I do it if that is all
cohesive if that feeling is good good
good good good then you found yourself a
ladder but if the answer is I find
myself drawn to do it and it feels good
when I do it but I feel like crap after
I do it that's a snake
that is a serpent okay Pop Quiz you're
absolutely famished after a hard days of
working on the field that was English
plowing
seeding cutting the grass and you come
into the door and you smell the Savory
smell of Mama's nectar I don't know what
that is but let's just say it's a meat
stew you smell the garlicky beefy
goodness as you walk in the front door
and you find yourself extremely tempted
to go and Gobble it down pour it down
your throat is that a snake or is that a
ladder
well it's probably a ladder because you
are working all day and you need a high
protein home-cooked stew that will
nourish you and help you recover your
muscles and you can take that nutrition
onwards in life it's just a win-win all
around there's both Temptation and a
deep sense of resolution and
satisfaction and nourishment that is a
ladder another quiz you're at the gym
busting out a set and some absolute Dime
Piece walks across your field of vision
you catch a glimpse and you say wow that
is crazy so let's just say noticing is a
moral neutral but you're confronted with
a choice continuing to stare is that a
snake or a ladder
well it's obviously a snake Because
unless you're using the beauty of this
person to motivate you to go form a
genuine relationship that is mutually
beneficial that's the only situation
that it would be a ladder but 99 of
people in that situation choose snake
they look for the angles they try to
bounce their Vision off of 16 different
mirrors to get a glimpse of the assets
but why is that a snake well what is it
doing for you it's making you want and
desire with absolutely no resolution
it's telling your brain that there is
value over there that I don't have and I
still don't have it and I still don't
have it and I want it and I want it and
I want it attraction is a tool just like
anything else but it's a tool to form
connection and if you're not actually
doing that then all you're doing is
teasing yourself and you're
subconsciously signaling to yourself
that wow there is Beauty in this world
and I don't have it do you think that is
towering feeling let me leave you with
this in Homer's Odyssey Odysseus didn't
strap himself to the Mast of the ship
because he was afraid of feeling good he
was aware of the siren's call he was
aware that the Temptation would have
been too strong because whatever
satisfaction it promised was just not
going to be worth it he was aware of the
snakes the sirens the dopaminergic
Temptation if what the sirens offered
actually felt good gave them something
of value that empowered them on their
Journey there would be no resistance but
the wise man knows that the siren offers
unfathomable pleasure but doesn't
deliver it's a sham quite literally the
definition of disorientation and
disintegration a distraction from the
mission so if you look at the bigger
picture
accumulating this sense of power has
nothing to do with avoiding pleasure in
fact it's quite the opposite it's about
avoiding the cheap and false proposition
of pleasure it's not falling for the
sirens who make things sound very
exciting and very tempting but don't
actually give you something in return if
you look at life with a broader scope
like this then climbing as many ladders
as you can in life actually offers you
more satisfaction and enjoyment both in
the long run and often right now when
you're doing something that you know
you're supposed to be doing and you
submit to it you submit to your destiny
and to your calling that feels good here
and now you know when you're finally
writing the paper that you've been
procrastinating forever and you're
sitting there in a flow state that feels
existentially satisfying you just want
to melt into that moment and ask
yourself why aren't I doing this all the
time that feeling of calm and duty is
power power is this feeling of
integration the person that we want to
be is the person that we are being
welcome to the IKEA furniture building
session holy smokes I look super tired
with this top down lighting there's no
I'm not using any fancy lighting so this
is what I look like in real life
I look 68 years old I want to take a
second to thank today's video sponsor
Audible and also recommend the audiobook
that I've been reading recently which is
the millionaire next door now if you
guys have been struggling financially
then there is no Financial book that I
recommend More Than The Millionaire Next
Door this book goes hand in hand with
what we are talking about in this video
it helps shift your mindset from chasing
the snakes in your financial life
slithering your money away on frivolous
things and help shift your mindset
towards genuine wealth building so you
can use your money to do more satisfying
things so give it a listen using today's
video sponsor Audible and for those of
you who don't know about audible it is
by far my favorite app on my phone
audible is the leading provider of
spoken word entertainment and audiobooks
all in one place as an audible member
every single month you receive one
credit which you can spend on any
audiobook of your choice regardless of
cost and you you get to keep that
audiobook forever if you ever cancel
your subscription at any point you still
keep your entire library of audiobooks
including the audiobooks that you got
for free using their credit system
audible members also get instant access
to a rapidly expanding catalog of
audible Originals podcasts and exclusive
Series so if you're interested in
joining me in becoming big brain and
just improving the quality of thoughts
that enter your skull on a day-to-day
basis then if you use my link in the
description below you'll get a free
30-day trial so click on my link in the
description below go to audible.com
better ideas or just text better ideas
to 500 500 to get your free 30-day trial
and thanks again to Audible for
sponsoring this video if you liked this
video make sure that you actually hit
the like button because when you hit the
like button it shoves my bald head into
other people's home pages helping them
out which also helps me out so it's a
win-win for everybody involved if your
lurk talking here and this is the
thousand million billionth brazilianth
time that you've seen my face consider
subscribing I don't know if it does
anything but I like to have more
subscribers
for the cloud other than that thank you
so much for watching and we'll catch you
in the next video
[Music]